In the instructor notes,
you'll find the URL for this revel.
The first step is, unsurprisingly,
on branch step one.
So, make sure you checked
it out correctly.
Now, let's go to Xcode.
Let's first take a look
at the main storyboard.
As you can see, it's very simple, and
it has one image view,
a slider, and three buttons.
The slider changes the alpha channel or
transparency of the image view.
So, it's basically there so
we can tell if the UI is blocked or not.
If you can move it while it's downloaded
it means the UI is not blocked.
Whenever you lick on
any of these buttons,
a large image will be downloaded.
This is by far the easiest way to block.
So for each button we'll
write a different action.
The first button, over here, sync, will
use a naive serial code that blocks.
The second button will use in
an asynchronous version using GCD.
And the last button,
will use a more elegant version
that takes a completion closure.
Let's get started.